this morning the search continues for
two-year-old amari nicholson
the boy was last seen wednesday near
paradise and twain and since then
the community has joined amari's family
to try and bring him home
madison kimbrough has that story we
can't sleep
we can't think about anything else when
we wake up
all we realize is another day has gone
by
and we don't know where amari is his
family completely distraught after
spending the weekend
searching for him and passing out flyers
around the emerald suites apartment
complex
off of paradise road sisters yolanda
everett and d'erika perryman
know there's a lot of confusion
involving this case but there's one
thing they want to clear up now
this person that took amari was not
his aunt it was not someone that is his
biological aunt
so if someone came to you and told you
that they're wrong
please help us find that person
initially it was amari's mother
taylor nicholson's boyfriend who said it
was an aunt that took the boy
walamari's mother and father are not on
speaking terms the aunts want to work
together with amari's mother to help
find her son we just all want to work
together with taylor to make sure that
we can bring him home
and stop the confusion i can understand
you and my brother not wanting to speak
to each other
but this is about omari you don't have
to talk to georgio
you can talk to me she's never met me
i'm a mom
this hurts me so i can only imagine how
she feels
i want to help her find her son madison
kimbrough 8 news now